Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlove und ich begrüße alle zur 1006. Ausgabe von UKW und,
geht's mal nicht
um den Krieg, sondern wir haben ja noch ein paar andere Krisen, die hier auch noch behandelt werden möchten und es äh drängt sich geradezu auf, mal wieder nach Großbritannien zu schauen, wo es äh wild hergeht. Und bevor wir da wieder alles verpassen und viel zu spät äh dran sind,
bei uns quatschen wir mal wieder und ich sage äh hallo zu John John Moers, hallo.
Und hallo wieder, ja.
Du bist grade äh auf Reisen, von daher haben wir leider heute nicht ganz die äh den technischen Standard hier bei unserer Soundqualität, wie wir es sonst gewohnt sind, aber wir äh kriegen das sicherlich auch so.
Hoffe ich. Also Grüße aus dem ländlichen Burgund in Frankreich.
Genau. Ähm ja.
Letzte Sendung äh war ziemlich genau vor drei Monaten. Das scheint sich bei uns ja hier auch ganz gut eingefunden zu haben, dass wir das ganze Geschehen eigentlich immer so im Quartal
beobachten und äh irgendwie scheint dann auch immer so nach drei Monaten wieder auch alles kopfzustehen
auf der Insel. Wir äh haben die letzte Sendung veröffentlicht,
im Mitte Juli und da befanden wir uns gerade hinter der Information, dass Boris Johnson dann final abtreten wird. Er ist ja dann noch eine Weile Ministerpräsident geblieben
Viele hat er dann nicht gemacht. Da gehen wir auch gleich noch mal drauf ein. Ähm.
Und äh wir standen kurz vor der Wahl der Neuwahl der Torries ihres äh ja ihrer Parteiführung. Ähm was ja dann immer dann bedeutet, dass damit dann auch die.
Positionen des Premierministers neu besetzt wird und,
äh ich glaube, wir waren so bei den letzten drei, ne, hatten wir
glaube ich, die Runde und ja wie das ausgegangen ist, werdet ihr alle schon mitbekommen haben, reden wir auch gleich drüber.
Aber bevor wir vielleicht ähm darauf kommen, würde mich natürlich noch mal so deinen Blick interessieren, wie denn
es eigentlich um den Brexit als solchen, steht also die Auswirkung aufs Land, auf der einen Seite, aber auch inwiefern eigentlich das Thema Brexit
in der Öffentlichkeit Großbritanniens präsent ist, weil zuletzt hatte man immer so den Eindruck, das ist so
Alle versuchen, das irgendwie wegzuschieben. Man hatte ja genug Ausreden, Corona, Ukraine-Krieg, sehr viel
alles war irgendwie Krisenenergiekrise kam jetzt noch mit dazu und es war dann immer alles andere Schuld, aber der Brexit war ja an gar nichts schuld und ich glaube auch die Leute, die so ein bisschen verstanden haben.
Ähm dass damit schon Schwierigkeiten verbunden sind haben sich auch nicht so richtig getraut darüber zu reden. Hat sich daran irgendwas,
geändert, was ist so deine Wahrnehmung der britischen Gesellschaft?
Ja nicht so hundert Prozent, also wir haben in den letzten sechs bis zwölf Monaten gesehen, eine leicht steigende,
Anteil der britischen.
Bevölkerung sagen, ja, das war eine Fehlentscheidung. Die Europäische Union zu verlassen. Aber auf der anderen Seite,
innerhalb der öffentlichen Diskussion sage ich in den Medien, ja und und und unter politischen Beteiligten
Da darf man das Wort Brexit fast überhaupt nicht sagen. Und das ist das natürlich
konservativen, die so eine Art Pro-Brexi-Partei geworden sind, die wollen dann nicht akzeptieren, dass sie haben eine falsche Entscheidung getroffen
und auf der anderen Seite die Labour Partei will so unbedingt wieder an der Macht kommen, dass die wollen,
dieses sich mit dieses Themenfeld auch nicht beschäftigen. Also das bedeutet, wir haben sie hier so zwei Ebenen. Auf eine Seite
Die Bewölkung beginnt so zu denken. Hey Moment mal, wir haben großen wirtschaftlichen Problemen. Brexit hat
alle diese Probleme so verschärft aber auf der anderen Seite die Politiker reden nicht so unbedingt darüber oder sage ich
nur die Ehe kleineren Parteien, also die schottischen Nationalisten oder die ähm ähm die die die Liblegrads. Also das ist ein bisschen den Hintergrund
Aber was wir auch sehen, was sehr, sehr wichtig ist für die jetzige Krise, ist die Wölzeln von die diese jetzige Krise gehen
hundert Prozent so den Brexit Volksabstimmung zurück und zu diese leaf Kampagne.
Diese alles wird besser nach dem Brexit. Also hat er überhaupt kein,
passte überhaupt nicht zu der wirtschaftliche Realität. Also damals in zwanzig sechs, in haben die Brexit-Befürworter
alle das ganze wirtschaftlichen Risiken des Brexits. Also einfach Projekt vier benannt. Ja so,
die EU verlassen ohne schwierigen wirtschaftlichen Folgen. Die haben gesagt, nee, das ist eine komplette Schwachsinn.
Aber jetzt merken wir, jetzt besonders in Sachen, die Energiepreisen, also das ist was am was ähm ähm am härtesten, die die britische Wirtschaft
äh gerade äh betrifft den Großbritannien, ist dieses Problem ist deutlich schwieriger zu beheben, weil Großbritannien aus der EU ausgetreten ist.
Es kam in in den Daily Telegraph ein ein interessantes Meinung so raus letzte Woche.
Projekt vier with, ja? Also dass die Brexit-Gegner härter in 2016
Recht. Ähm also irgendwie beginnt die Diskussion jetzt ein sich ein bisschen zu ändern, aber das kam bei den Politiker, besonders bei den Konservativen und bei Labour bisher nie.
Und die gut, also Medien, Politiker, das ist so das eine und was ist so deine Wahrnehmung, wie die Gesellschaft das selber, äh das wahrnimmt?
Ja, so die man merkt in Großbritannien, dass die Situation inzwischen.
Ziemlich ernst ist. Aber und das ist irgendwie schief läuft. Die Frage ist, inwiefern ist diese Wahrnehmung, dass,
Brexit ein Teil des Problems ist oder das ist das.
Die Leute in die in die höchsten Ebenen besonders in der Regierung.
Überhaupt keine Ahnung haben von wie man diese Arten von Problemen löst ähm und.
Bisher alle reden über zu den alltäglichen politischen Krisen
aber nicht über die eher langfristigeren Änderungen des britischen Gesellschafts oder Wirtschafts,
dann gegen Wurzeln haben in die in den Austritt aus der Europäische Union. Ähm also
Ich kriege den den Eindruck, dass diese Diskussion ist bisher irgendwie nicht reif. Man hat.
Platz und Zeit um um um Tiefe nachzudenken hatte man bisher nicht, ja weil man steckte,
Besonders in den letzten so sage ich vier bis sechs Wochen einfach in so eine dauerhafte Krise. Und wenn man in so eine dauerhafte Krise ist, ist natürlich ziemlich schwierig die langfristigere Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen.
Na ja klar, das lenkt äh
aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass es zumindest der Wirtschaft selbst, zumindest den Teilen, die sich bisher zu wenig Gedanken gemacht haben, auch einfach den politischen Aussagen geglaubt haben. So gab ja auch viele Unternehmer, die
das auch nicht so richtig,
verstanden haben oder nicht verstehen wollten, welche Auswirkungen das hat, aber die Auswirkungen sind ja real, ja. Also die
jetzt nicht alle Zahlen parat, aber ich denke ähm grob kann man sagen, der ganzen Ausfuhren äh von Groß
nach Europa sind, also glaube ich mindestens um ein Drittel eingebrochen. Also es sind massive äh Verluste, die dort.
Zu erzielen sind, weil einfach viele europäische Unternehmen sagen
ja sorry, aber den Stress äh von euch zu importieren, den den den mache ich mir erst gar nicht. Größere Unternehmen haben's dadurch kompensiert, dass sie dann Niederlassungen in Polen, Deutschland, Frankreich äh
Niederlande et cetera aufgesetzt haben. Von dort also dann sozusagen schon noch exportieren, aber dann halt immer so Bike Export machen, aber die ganzen,
werden dann eben von europäischen Unternehmen durchgeführt. Die Steuern müssen dort,
werden. Die Mitarbeiter, die dort arbeiten, äh tragen natürlich dann zu den jeweiligen
Wirtschaften bei, aber eben nicht mehr zu der Wirtschaft von UK und das sind natürlich Auswirkungen, die sind auf dem Papier, die kann man nicht weg,
und ich habe so den Eindruck, die Wirtschaft selber versteht das jetzt und noch hinzuzufügen, dass es ja nur die Situation bei den größeren Unternehmen,
diesen Aufwand leisten können, während halt kleine Unternehmen, so hohe Selbstständige et cetera Unternehmen mit ein paar, die
Genau, die die den die verlieren dann den Markt und wenn die einfach mit dem lokalen Markt nicht überleben können, dann ist halt äh vorbei.
Ja das stimmt aber was man nicht hat als Bürger oder als Unternehmer ist irgendein Weg,
diese Situation irgendwie zu ändern. Wie kann man Druck.
Ausüben und natürlich auch es gibt diese politische Spannungen, weil Lisstraße hat vor kurzem gesagt, dass,
sie will die britische Wirtschaft von dem Last der so verbliebene EU-Regeln.
Möglichst rasch so entlasten.
Was wir nicht wissen ist, erstens stimmt das überhaupt, funktioniert das? Und zweitens, wegen die kurzfristige politische Krise, man weiß ja nicht, ob sie das überhaupt hinkriegt. Also das bedeutet, dass
Unternehmer, so entweder groß oder klein, wie trifft man und den jetzigen Umständen überhaupt Entscheidungen in Großbritannien? Weil man weiß ja nicht, was tun,
die Regierung überhaupt. Ja, also ist mal die Regierung dann oder auch andere anderen Aspekten.
Großbritannien kontrolliert LKWs bei der Einfahrt in Großbritannien
bisher nicht. Weil die haben die Regierung hatte die die Kontrollstation und so bisher nicht gebaut und und nicht alles implementiert. Aber natürlich,
als Unternehmer, man weiß ja nicht, kommen diese Kontrollen jetzt in drei Monaten?
Zwölf Monaten oder dann überhaupt nicht. Also das bedeutet, dass es gibt,
Keine Sicherheit
ja? Sobald man weiß, okay, das ist, was dann kommen wird, könnte man dann Entscheidungen treffen. Aber zur Zeit, man reagiert, also von dem einen Tag bis dem nächsten und
diese diese Unsicherheit ist ist, was so so auch so sehr störend.
Ja und vor allem ist natürlich dieses in Anführungsstrichen Versprechen, dass man jetzt äh Großbritannien von.
Wie Lys Trost das so schön formuliert hat. Wir werden nachher noch sehr viel mehr über sie reden. Ähm ja von dieser Last der äh bürokratischen Regeln, das ist ja auch diese
äh anti äh Sprache, also die Brexit
äh Sprache, die ja eigentlich vollkommen verschleiert, dass die Last dadurch ja noch sehr viel größer wird, weil in dem Moment, wo jetzt ein britisches Unternehmen andere Regularien hat
sagen wir mal in der industriellen Produktion, was Standards betrifft et cetera, dann sehen sich die Unternehmen ja vor der Situation, dass sie zwar andere Standards für ihren eigenen Markt
machen äh erfüllen müssen. Trotzdem sind ja die Regelungen der EU nicht,
in der EU, sondern in gewisser Hinsicht auch weltweit der Standard, weil sich ja alle eigentlich nach dem bürokratischen Standard der EU richten, weil es einfach vollkommen sinnlos ist, nach irgendwelchen anderen Standards zu produzieren, weil dann muss man ja alles zwei, drei Mal,
produzieren. Das heißt, es würde ja dann die Last noch erhöhen.
In den letzten Monaten, wir haben schon ein paar Beispiele davon, ja also die die Regierung hat gesagt, ja so wir treten aus den ähm ähm so ähm äh Datenschutzverordnungen,
raus. Und alle britischen IT-Unternehmen haben's an meine Gute, nee, das geht nicht oder dass die aus, also das ist eine eine eine Gesetzgebung der EU für Registrierung von Chemikalien und dann hat die ganze
Chemieindustrie in Großbritannien gesagt. Im Moment mal, das kostet uns zu viel so danach auszutreten
und um alle Blödesten hat die die EU ähm entschieden jetzt vor ein paar Wochen.
USB-C aus ähm so Ladestandard für Handys und elektrische Geräte zu verwenden
nee, das tun wir nicht, ja? Aber was ist das dann? Das Appo produziere dann ein ein iPhone für Großbritannien immer nochmal in deinem Lightning-Kabel und und nicht mit einem Mikro-USB. Es geht auf keinen Fall. Äh also und,
Das sind nur die Beispiele aus den letzten paar Monaten. Also dieses Idee, dass man kann sich von diese Regelungen dann befreien und man gewinnt dann wirtschaftlich. Ja also das.
So weit wir wissen, geht nicht. Aber das war ein zentraler Punkt vom,
die Diskussionen von Lears, also was sie vorgeschlagen hat, um überhaupt dann.
Parteichef der Conservy zu werden und das sagt sie halbwegs,
immer noch, ja, obwohl wir natürlich dann gar nicht wissen, ob das überhaupt wirkt.
Gut. Schließen wir jetzt erst mal da an, wo wir zuletzt aufgehört haben und äh blicken wir ein letztes Mal hoffentlich äh,
auf den Werdegang von Boris Johnson. Er hatte ja dann sozusagen sein
eingeleitet. Das war ja klar, aber er war auch klar, dass er dann noch über den Sommer Premierminister bleiben würde. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wofür er es genutzt hat. Ich habe
nur ein paar Reisen in die Ukraine gesehen und wahrscheinlich gab's auch noch ein paar Reisen in irgendwelche Urlaubsländer. Äh inhaltliches nichts passiert, ne.
Er hat wenig getan möglicherweise.
Wir haben so gefischt, hey Moment mal wenn er immer arm bleibt zerstört er was.
Er hat am Ende wenig getan und für seine Verhältnis äh
ziemlich wenig zerstört. Ja, also er hatte sein Hochzeitfest gehabt in, außer dem den ländlichen, so House für der Premierminister ja, aber
ganz grundsätzlich, ja, also.
Für den jetzigen Verhältnissen, also diese some Periode zwischen Ende Juli und Anfang September war dann.
Ziemlich ruhig, ja. Ähm was wir vielleicht diskutieren müssen, ist.
Was hatte Sudan gelassen äh und inwiefern war.
Hat er dann diese Kaos nach ihm hat er selber eingeleitet, weil.
Er hat seine eigene, so Kabinett war,
ziemlich schwach ja und zwei von den führenden Personen, Persönlichkeiten, aus dem Kabinett von Boris Johnson waren dann
in diese Urwahl, also für für seine Nachfolger, ja, so den ausgehenden Finanzminister Sunnac.
In den ausgehenden Außenministerin und.
Es war für Boris Johnson sehr, sehr wichtig, dass er wäre die der stärkste in seinem eigenen Kabinett. Also er hätte.
Bessere und stärkeren Leute innerhalb der Reihen der der konservativen Abgeordnete gefunden können, aber das hat er nicht getan. Er ist so ein Kabinett so gesammelt, die einfach dann.
Immer
bereit wären, ihm zu unterstützen. Also was bedeutet dann ein Nachfolger für ihn zu finden,
war dann ziemlich schwierig, weil er war dann,
Er hat niemand so aufgebaut. Und das führte dann zu Problemen dann um ein ein Nachfolge ähm überhaupt
zu finden. Und was auf sie nicht wichtig war, er hatte bis seinen letzten Tagen mehr Unterstützung unter den Parteimitglieder der Konservativen als er je hatte
und äh den Abgeordneten. Also sein Sou ist ein Abgang war mir.
So produziert wegen seinen Verhältnissen zu den anderen Abgeordneten als Problemen bei den konservativer Parteimitglieder, wo ein und auch heute noch eine gewisse Unterstützung hat.
Ja das ist wirklich skurril, ne? Also da merkt man aber mal wieder, ich meine er wird ja immer so als.
In den Medien so als charismatisch beschrieben. Das ist äh etwas, was man, glaube ich, so aus aus unserer Position heraus fällt, uns das ein bisschen schwer.
Ja in Großbritannien.
Ja aber man kann einfach niemals und sollte auch niemals unterschätzen, was so bisschen auch.
Die Verbundenheit von Wählern und und der Bevölkerung zu solchen Figuren manchmal ausmacht. Die ist halt,
nicht davon getragen, was äh jemand macht und auch nicht unbedingt davon, wie intellektuell jemand,
ja äh generell hat ja auch diese ganze Brexit-Kampagne gezeigt, dass so intellektualität und das ähnliche Bewegung sehen wir auch weltweit.
Ja dann auch oft also als Gegenargument benutzt wird, ne. Das sind dann die Eliten und so weiter. Was bei ihm natürlich besonders irre ist, weil er ist ja nun wirklich.
Ein volles Produkt der Eliten, ja, nur dass er sich eben nicht so push äh
aufführt, sondern eben immer so rumpelig äh rüberkam wie so ein Bauer und äh einfach überhaupt,
nicht jetzt so ein Snoop war wie was weiß ich hier äh Jacke Breasmog oder so, der dann einfach auch nochmal
besonders verkörpert was es ist, aber trotzdem auch in der Lage ist gegen die Eliten zu schimpfen. Also es ist einfach alles es ist alles so furchtbar absurd. Trotzdem so als Typ kann man halt einfach immer irgendwie
an, auch wenn da eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur noch gelogen äh hat und einfach nix gestimmt hat, was er gesagt hat und einfach auch das, was er gesagt hat, auch an sich
äh keinerlei Substanz hatte. Es war einfach nur immer so ein bisschen daher geredet.
Ja, aber es ist ja sehr interessant, weil man schaut hier neben einem so Umfragen, also.
Die konservative Wähler haben ihm nie so wirklich vertraut. Hä? Also,
die konservative Parteimitglieder, ne, einige Abgeordneten haben dieses Ruf von Boris Johnson so aufgebaut.
Haben, die ihn benannt, vor allem nach dem Spruch von Heineken in in aus der Werbung in Großbritannien. Also war den Spruch von von ähm äh ähm äh von von Heiniken jahrelang.
Die den konservativen Partei sonst nie erreichen könnte.
Aber er war nie selber besonders populär. Das das Vorteil für die konservativen in 2019 war Jeremy Cobin war besonders unpopulär. Ja so.
Einfach Wähler, die normale weiße Label wählen, wollten auf keinen Fall Jeremy Kobin dann unterstützt
Also das bedeutet, dass die Konservativen als Partei, nicht unter die Partei, die Leute, die für die Partei gestimmt haben, haben so dieses Huf von Boris Johnson enorm so
blasen und das das er er war so eine Art Räte der Partei und und dieses Ruf,
bleibt heute noch zum Teil also als Gültig.
Den sehr schmalen Kreisen der Parteimitglieder.
Ja? Und das ist dann sehr wichtig, weil das sind dann diese Parteimi,
die dann für seine Nachfolge gestimmt
haben ähm und das ist was dann zu zu dieses die in der jetzigen Paul Martin Situation dann dann führt.
Gut dann setzen wir doch mal jetzt direkt da an, wo wir letztes Mal aufgehört haben. Es gab ja dann die Neuwahl.
Und ähm uns nochmal aufzuzählen. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir den letzten Podcast gemacht haben, waren im Rennen Richie Sunac
die beiden waren ja dann am Ende. Äh auch diejenigen, über die dann die Partei abstimmen durften zur Erinnerung,
läuft ja dann immer so. Erstmal gibt es äh einzelne Wahlen äh es wird sozusagen immer einer rausgewählt oder,
äh Stimmen werden eingesammelt und wir haben am wenigsten im Kopffeld äh unten raus und so wird dann das Teilnehmerfeld immer weiter reduziert, bis es nur noch zwei sind und dann wird das eben
der Partei vorgelegt. Das heißt, die Parteimitglieder dürfen dann wählen und entscheiden letzten Endes zwischen den letzten beiden. Wir hatten dann, glaube ich, äh
Als es noch drei waren und das war dann Penny modern, die noch mit äh im Boot war?
Du hattest glaube ich äh gemeint, das könnte sie vielleicht werden, ist sie dann aber nicht.
Ja, aber das ist dann ein das war dann am Ende ziemlich knapp. Zwischen die die drei und das ist dann.
Ja, es gibt halt Gerüchten um um die die diese Situation. Also in alle anderen Gründen, der der der Vorwahl unter Abgeordneten.
War auf dem ersten Platz.
Dann Mode runter auf den,
und dann alle anderen dahinter und dann in diese letzte Runde hat dann
hat sich durchgesetzt. Also die Zahlen waren 137 für,
13 Abgeordneten für Truss und 15 für Mode und also was ziemlich knapp, also
unter ein Drittel der Abgeordneten,
haben dann in diese letzte Runde Truss überhaupt unterstützt. Und es gab ja Gerüchten, dass einige Unterstützer haben dann für.
Für ähm für Truss gestimmt, damit nicht in die letzte so Runde kommt
und den Parteimitglieder. Also das das es wäre besser für
In die letzte Runde gegen Tross anzutreten als gegen. Also das wissen wir nicht. Aber es gab so eine rundum Gerüchten da innerhalb der Partei.
So ist es ja auch gelaufen, als es äh um Boris Johnston's Wahl ging, ne? Das.
Aber aber.
In in den in den vorherigen Situationen ähm es gab ja nur zwei, ja also ähm Cameron und Boris Johnson. Da war
waren die die Leute, die dann sich durchgesetzt haben, aufführend und ab die Abgeordneten, ja?
Theresa May Premierministerin geworden ist, da trat Andrea letzten aus dem Rennen, also da kam es nie so eine Urwahl unter den Parteimitgliedern. Aber das ist das erste Mal und diese
diese Prozedere, also diese getrennte Prozedere, die Abgeordneten stimmen zuerst, also die äh damit es dann zu nur zwei Kandidaten kommen und dann die Parteimitglieder,
in die beiden vorherigen Malen, als die das so getan haben, wie dieses Mal war der Person, der am Ende gewonnen hat.
Auch bei den Abgeordneten gewonnen,
diesmal hat Trus vorbei den Abgeordneten so verloren, hatte eine Unterstützung von weniger als ein Drittel der Abgeordneten,
Aber hat sich dann bei den Parteimitglieder mit 8160.000 Stimmen,
durchgesetzt.
Also das bedeutet, dass Trus war beliebte unter den Mitglieder als unter den Abgeordneten. Und das kann man dann so sagen, das führte dann,
zu Problemen als Trust begonnen hat, dann zu regieren, weil sie hatte diese gewisse Unterstützung unter den eigenen Kollegen nicht. Ähm also das ist dann eine ziemlich problematische Situation,
für für und man man merkt ja so
Es gab eine 80 Prozent Wahlbeteiligung unter den konservativen Parteimitgliedern. Ja so 14.000 haben äh haben abgestimmt. Also man merkt da, dass diese Partei eine ziemlich
kleine Bewegung ist, ja. Auch die die deutsche CDU hat doppelt so viele Mitglieder, als die die britischen Torys. Also das bedeutet, die,
wie viel hatte.
Am Beginn als sie gewählt worden ist als Parteichefin am 5. September. Das war dann schon am Beginn ziemlich fraglich.
Warum haben denn die äh Mitglieder sie gewählt und nicht äh.
Wir haben dieses diesen Satz im Englischen he would wheels the sourd.
Will never where the Crown. Und Sunac war hat eine entscheidende Rolle gespielt für den.
So die Ende vom äh von Boris Johnson,
der ist zurückgetreten und das führte dann.
Den ähm Rücktritt von Boris Johnson. Und was Trus.
Richtig gut verstanden hat, war Boris Johnson war unter den Parteimitglieder noch ziemlich populär.
Also Tross hat sich dann selber als so Boris Johnsons Nachfolgereden,
präsentiert. Und das kam bei den Parteimitgliedern ziemlich gut an. Und zweitens, was Trust getan hat, die Linie von Trass war so eine Art.
Post-Faturis. Ja, also eine Senkung.
Der der besonders der der Posensaal der äh der Einkommenssteuer in Großbritannien, was
Selber auch Gitarren hatte in der Achtziger. Also das bedeutet, dass Trus hat zwei Dingen.
Richtig verstanden um Parteichefin zu werden. Erstens die Linie vom,
Boris Johnson nicht zu heftig zu zu kritisieren und zweitens sich also als als Nachfolgerin von Margaret zu präsentieren. Und das sind dann die, das ist warum sie.
Kaum sage ich ziemlich gut bei den Mitgliedern an. Aber nicht nur ziemlich gut. Es die Erwartung,
War so mitten in diese Urwahlprozedere im Sommer im August. Das Truss könnte.
Mit einer überragenden Mehrheit dann gewinnen. Was sie am Ende,
nicht getan hat, ja, das war keine überragende Mehrheit für LiS Strass aus 75 zu 3undvierzig. Am Beginn der Oval-Leute ging davon aus, es könnte so mindestens zwei Drittel, so sogar vielleicht 70 Prozent.
Weil die die Schwächen von. Besonders bei der Kommunikation
ja? Kamen auch während dieses Urwahlprozedere dann schon raus. Sie kommuniziert nach so einem sehr schwachen Art und Weise. Das ist irgendwie sehr robotisch. Ja, es kommt rüber. Und dann
die dies diese Entscheidung zwischen den beiden, die beiden.
Könnten niemand so wirklich überzeugen. Ja also es war eine sehr lange und langweilige und und und,
keine überragende so besonders gute Prozedere, ja? Also was bedeutet genug getan,
um zu gewinnen, aber hat niemand so wirklich überzeugt.
Und was dann auch sehr wichtig ist, ja, ist Sunac hat die wirtschaftliche Pläne von Listes. Hart kritisiert.
Ja, er hat gesagt, wenn sie tut, was sie sagt, führe das dann so eine Finanzkrise in Großbritannien.
Und niemand, ich ich gehöre auch selber dazu. Niemand hat wirklich daran geglaubt, ja. Nee, das tut sie nicht. Das das sagt sie nur, um diese Urwald zu gewinnen und nur um Parteichef.
Äh dann äh zu werben. Und wir kommen dann zu was sie dann getan hat. Aber einfach zu sagen.
Sie ist in einem Aspekt anders als Boris Johnson. Boris Johnson hat.
So viel vorgeschlagen und angeboten und und und gesagt, dass er alles tut für allen und das hat er am am Ende nicht getan, ja? Er hat nicht geliefert.
War am Ende blöd genug.
Zu machen, was sie die Parteimitglieder angeboten hat. Und das ist dann das große Unterschied, wie wie anderen gesagt haben, she was high on here own supply, also sie hat sie hat einfach.
Selber sucht zu viel an an dem geglaubt, was ich selber gesagt hat. Ja ähm und das und und die Schlussfolgerung davon haben wir dann jetzt äh im im September und Oktober dann äh dann dann erlebt.
Ja, also sie wurde dann äh eben gewählt und ist dann am welchen Datum?
Ja, es war das Ergebnis kam am 5. September raus. Sie ist am 6. September Premierministerin endgültig geworden und dann nur zwei Tage später starb die Königin.
8. September.
Also das bedeutet
Und dann die Beerdigung, wir kommen in kurzes die die Rolle der Königin, die Beerdigung der Königin war am 19. September, also das bedeutet, dass dem ersten zwei Wochen von
die Abendzeit von Listes, die haben die Briten fast ausschließlich,
die Situation mit die Beerdigungen die Rolle der Königin beschäftigt. Also sie begann nur wirklich.
Sage ich so normalen politischen Aufgaben dann erst am zwanzig.
September. Also das ist nur ein Monat her, ja, weil wir sind jetzt am 2. Oktober, ja. So ist das lief alles sehr schief.
Schon sehr schnell.
Ja, kommen wir mal äh zur Queen.
Die äh ja so ein bisschen äh immer den Eindruck machte, als würde sie nie sterben. Meinte sie war jetzt, wie lange Königin über siebzig.
Über 70 Jahren, ja.
Ne äh und ist natürlich jetzt eine Persönlichkeit, die einfach die ganze Welt äh.
Mental im im Griff hatte, weil sie eben irgendwie immer da war. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Premierminister hat sie erlebt äh da muss man richtig anfangen zu zählen, also äh gefühlt.
Über zehn Premierenminister. Ich denke, es war 11 oder 12 Premierminister.
Aber aber aber irgendjemand hat so kalkuliert. Nach den jetzigen ähm so
Geschwindigkeit wie wie viele Premierminister es ja geben könnte in Großbritannien. Charles würde ungefähr 600 bei mir Herr Minister.
Während seine arm seid. Dann haben, wenn er so lang lebt wie die Königin.
Ähm es war leider ein ziemlich lustiger Cargfühl, aber ja, ganz grundsätzlich. Sie hatte.
Sie hatte eine sehr lange Armzeit gehabt, aber was sie selber.
Für die britische politische System tut.
War nie so wirklich bekannt. Was hat sie gebremst oder irgendwie gestoppt? Als Boris Johnson.
Vor dem Brexit-Abstimmungen einfach das Parlament einen Monat lang
außer Kraft gesetzt hatte in zwanzig neunzehn. Diese sogenannten Proregation of Parliment, ja ähm das haben wir in einem vorherigen Podcast debattiert. Es war ja klar, dass so was
politisch und akzeptabel sei. Und es gab damals eine Diskussion, könnte die Königin so was einfach.
Aber es geht nicht. Bitte tut das einfach nicht. Und die Königin hat das damals nicht getan oder oder vielleicht hat sie das vorgeschlagen und Boris Johnson hat das dann trotzdem gemacht. Also.
Inwiefern war die königliche Familie so eine Art Bremse gegen die.
Ehe blödsinnigere Sachen, die in den letzten Jahren.
Die reguläre Politiker vielleicht versucht hätten, das haben wir nie mit die Königin.
Das wussten wir nicht, ja.
Sie herrschte für eine Art Stabilität, aber was wäre dann die alltägliche politische Rolle der Königin? Also es gibt und gab einmal pro Woche,
eintreffen zwischen die Königinnen und jetzt mit dem zwischen den König und dem jetzigen Premierminister. Aber
Was war die Rolle? Was für ein Einfluss hatte die Königin? Das wussten wir nie. Also sie war immer da, sie war immer präsent aber sagte
nie was politisches, also hat sich immer rausgehalten aus den alltäglichen Debatten.
Und das haben wir schon erlebt mit Schals. Also es gab schon eine öffentliche Streit zwischen ihm.
Und liest Charles. Also er wollte so den COP27 in Ägypten in November dieses Jahr
äh fahren und er war auf vorherigem Copreffen der freien Nationen und es ist jetzt bekannt, dass liest Schraus will nicht, dass das King Charles dann zu den Korp treffen fährt in Ägypten.
Ähm also sowas wäre.
Käme nie raus unter die Königin, also das bedeutet, dass Großbritannien muss jetzt sich mit eine neue Ära irgendwie klarkommen und und und,
Also hm es waren 9 Gewicht.
So Ballens irgendwie zwischen die königliche Familie ähm und die sage ich die normale Politiker.
Erklär mir doch mal also was ist denn die reale tatsächliche, wirkliche im Gesetz festgeschriebene Macht in Anführungsstrichen, die,
die Königin hatte oder der König jetzt hat. Also was was ist tatsächlich wirklich der der juristischen, mögliche Einfluss und was ist, sagen wir mal, nur so ein mentaler,
Einfluss, den äh diese Rolle auf die Bevölkerung und dann indirekt auf die Politik hat. Was ist da dran.
Das Problem ist, dass wissen wir nicht so genau. Da ist. Nehmen wir das.
Also juristisch muss man's doch wissen. Also ich meine.
Es ist alles auf Prinzipien oder auf ähm.
Es ist nirgendwo komplett juristisch geregelt, weil Großbritannien keine geschriebene Verfassung hat.
Nehmen wir das Beispiel.
Oder weiterhin und.
Es besteht jetzt wieder die Macht, ein ein Neuwahlen auszurufen.
Dieses Macht hat den Premierminister oder Premierministerin und wenn morgen Lese geht zu den König und sagt ich will Neuwahlen.
Ist das möglich, dass der König sagt nein, das geht nicht,
Das ist auf dem Basis von den sogenannten. Und diese sind nicht juristisch und die greifen zurück auf diese Idee,
gebe es eine auternative Premierminister oder Ministerin, der oder die über eine Mehrheit in den britischen Unterhaus verfügt.
Wieso könnte Prinz Charles dann wissen, ob es eine adernative Premierminister überhaupt,
gebe, der oder die über ein ein Mehrheit dann verfügt. Das wissen wir nicht, wie Prince Charles so was dann, als sorry, King Charles überhaupt.
So was herausfinden könnte. Weil das nie zustande gekommen ist seit Jahrzehnten.
So, das bedeutet, dass auf Papier könnte Charles eingreifen, in der Realität wird er erst das nicht tun. Sowas bedeutet diese Art von Sachen, die wissen wir dann nicht.
Was sind das für principles, die du gerade genannt.
Hießen die.
Wie schreibt sich das?
L A S C E L ES.
Sehr kurz zusammengefasst, diese waren zehn Jahre lang außer Kraft, weil es gab eine neue Regelung, wie man einen und Auswahl ausruft.
Eingeführt von ähm David Cameron und diese, die und
Boris Johnson mochte diese Regelungen aus der Zeit von Bori, von Camon nicht und haben diese dann Regelungen dann abgeschafft und wie sind jetzt so zu den Regelungen von vor 20 11 zurückgekehrt?
So
Aber das bedeutet, dass falls Großbritannien jetzige politische Krise in Großbritannien eine Art konstitutionelle Krise wird, dass.
Liest Tross überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist, zu regieren, selber kein ähm kein Neuwahlen ausruft.
Aber ein Misstrauensvotum eingeleitet von der Labour Partei nicht erfolgreich wäre, also das bedeutet, dass um damit ein Misstrauensvotum.
Erfolgreich sein muss müssen.
Irgendwas zwischen 30 und 40 konservativen Abgeordneten auch dann für den.
Misstrauen in den eigenen Partei oder in die eigene Regierung dann stimmen.
Aber wegen die jetzige Situation der Konservativen in den Meinungsumfragen das führe dann.
So ein Machverlust für die Konservativen, also man könnte eine Situation haben, dass Neuwahlen sind nicht möglich, weil die Konservativen wollen kein neu, keine Neuwahlen, aber.
Die können ganz grundsätzlich nicht regieren, weil Schuss verfügt über keinerlei Mehrheit, um irgendwas.
Durchführen zu können.
Und das ist die fast die jetzige Position. Also ist es dann eine Frage könnte der König dann eingreifen und sagen okay wir brauchen jetzt Neuwahlen.
Rein theoretisch schon, aber in die Realität nicht.
Ja. Sorry, das ist ein bisschen kompliziert ist, ja, aber aber so ist es.
Ja, weil das so kompliziert ist, machen wir diesen Podcast ähm.
Ja ja.
Lass uns doch mal kurz bei bei der Queen äh bleiben. Was,
Ähm wie muss man sich, ich meine klar, das war jetzt natürlich medial sehr präsent und irgendwie tagelang wurden da diese Warteschlangen gezeigt und Anteilnahme und Pipapo und große Reden und die Beerdigung und so weiter. Ich habe mich da äh gleich so ein bisschen ausgeklinkt. Ich hatte da gar keinen.
Äh aufzunehmen, aber es ist natürlich klar, dass das für die britische Bevölkerung natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein Symbol für eine Zeitenwende ist.
Was auch immer dann folgt, aber es ist jetzt einfach eine Ära es äh zu Ende, ja? Die Person, die auf jedem ähm auf jedem Geldschein äh gedruckt ist und auf jeder.
Irgendwie ihr Siegel äh hatte, ist jetzt einfach nicht mehr da und die hat natürlich einer ganzen Generation, ich meine, es gibt ja einfach sehr sehr wenige,
die überhaupt länger als sie gelebt haben so ja also so jeder jeder der irgendwie noch äh in Großbritannien derzeit lebt äh,
kennt die Queen als Queen und die war schon irgendwie immer da. Was macht das also was.
Wie schätzt du diese Wirkung äh dieses Moments auf die Bevölkerung ein? Kann das auch,
deuten, so nach dem Motto.
Jetzt ist die Queen tot, jetzt ist auch irgendwie alles andere egal oder jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt ändern sich äh Dinge,
kann gibt's so einen Effekt oder wie wirkt das auf das Land.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass da herrscht so eine Art Unsicherheit, einfach mal das.
Es gab schon dieses Gefühl, dass.
Großbritannien ist nicht mehr, was Großbritannien irgendwie vorher war. Äh also diese dieser.
Diese Gedanke oder diese diese Diskussion begann schon längst vor der Tod der Königin, aber.
Das war so eine sie war so eine Art Brücke, so diese alte Ära.
Aber was für eine Rolle sie dann spielte. Was das muss man dann auch nicht übertreiben. Also aus der BBC dann einfach dann.
So tagelang berichtet nur über den Tod der Königin.
Gab's auch eine ziemlich starke Gegenreaktion. Also sorry, das ist ein bisschen zu viel, ja? Also die haben ein paar so Amateure Fußballteams wollen einfach ein Turnier noch spielen. Und dann die
da kamen dann die Polizisten, sagen, hey Moment, also das sei nicht akzeptabel, ein Fußballturnier zu spielen, ein paar Tage nach dem Tod der Königin, das war.
Das ist dann.
Nicht nur die Amateure, auch die Profis haben ja aufgehört zu.
Ja, die Profis haben da auch nicht gespielt, ja, aber und dann all das man hat so einfach dann dieses Idee, so Moment mal. Das ist einfach zu viel. Also das ist nur.
Sie das war eine sehr wichtige Person, ja klar. Aber Moment mal. Also das das alltägliche Leben.
Stoppt nicht oder so, ja ähm äh und,
und noch was mit mit Fußball zu tun, also mehr mehr Briten haben das so das Finale von ähm äh Euro zwanzig20 angeschaut als die Beerdigung der Königin.
Ähm äh so es gibt.
Ich denke, dass die die das diese Diskussion in den Medien hat sie dargestellt als mehr so eine eine Art.
So sehr zentrale Figur als vielleicht die War der Situation in der Realität, weil.
Einen Seestarkenpunkt der Königin. Also was für eine Rolle sie genau spielte war nie so sehr präzis. Ja, es war immer ein bisschen vage. Und das war ein Grund, warum es dann,
nie so umstritten war, dass die die Rolle der königlichen Familie aus sie selber noch im Armt
Und das habe ich, ich habe
persönlich jahrelang Geld an den Republik Kampagne in Großbritannien Geld gegeben, ja, weil ich bin für eine britische Republik, die Abschaffung der Königliche Familie. Ich habe immer gesagt, ja warte bis Charles der König ist und dann
wirklich eine Debatte über die Zukunft der königlichen Familie. Weil die Königin ist ziemlich klug, hält sich
aus die meisten Debatten. Aber das bedeutet, dass dieses Idee, dass sie wäre irgendwie,
ganz grundsätzlich irgendwie geliebt oder so. Ja unter einem bestimmten Teil der Bewölkung schon. Aber das war kein.
Generelles Gefühl. Es war einfach jahrzehntelang es war nicht politisch erlaubt.
Gegen die königliche Familie irgendwas zu sagen. Das war so äh die beiden Parteichefs, der jetzige.
Parteien. Tross und und aus Studenten die beiden haben sich,
gegen eine königliche Familie und für eine britische Republik geäußert
Und irgendwann mal, als die dann reguläre und Karrieren begonnen haben, war es dann nicht mehr akzeptabel zu sagen, hey Moment mal, wir brauchen eine britische Republik. Das war nie möglich. Also das hat man einfach
nie debattiert ähm und.
Aber auf der anderen Seite einfach so mal zu sagen, die wahren beliebte oder irgendwie
total unkomplett. Die haben ja mehr Unterstützung als andere politische Akteure. Aber das bedeutet das vielleicht, dass andere politische Akteure anderen Schwächen haben und gehasst sind, aus meiner Sicht, es gibt keine.
Keine sind so in in der gesamte Bewölkung, keine so sehr sehr tiefe Beliebtheit.
Mhm. Na ja also es gibt also auf jeden Fall Teile der Gesellschaft, die das Spiel ja auch nicht mitgespielt haben, wo wir schon beim
waren. Es gab ja dann glaube ich ein Spiel äh mit Celtic Glasgow. Das ist ja so ein bisschen der ähm katholische äh Teil schon
der hinter dieser Mannschaft äh steht, wo dann auch ein Spiel war, wo dann irgendwie geklatscht werden sollte für die Queen und dann haben die gezelt die Glaskohlfans dann angefangen zu singen irgendwie.
Ja und ja und natürlich ist es auch besonders problematisch, Teil
auch natürlich die königliche Familie hatte dieses Bezug zu Schottland zum Teil, aber die sage ich.
Aber das war so eine ziemlich elitäre Verbindung da auch, ja. Ähm.
Die Schlösser äh große Bilanzbesitz hatte.
Ja, die Schlösser und auch dann Prinz Charles war Prince Wales und jetzt die die Unabhängigkeitsbewegung in Wales hat, hey Moment mal, also wir wir wollen keinen keinen zukünftigen Prince Wales bitte. Also lass uns
bitte raus. Ähm also ähm ja also Spannungen gibt es ja schon, ja. Ähm.
Aber es gibt jetzt wieder ein Prince of Wales.
Ja ähm nee aber.
Also der der Sohn, der der Sohn von äh ähm wie heißt er?
William genau, der ist ja jetzt äh Prince of Wales äh geworden.
Aber irgendwie.
Nur nur ein ziemlich ungewöhnliches Beispiel. Ich war schon in Frankreich an den Tagen als die die Königin starb und ich war in einem Zug und ein.
Total unbekannte, ja, der bei dem bei dem Ausstrahlen, bei dem Zug an der Französisch so gefragt,
Oh bist du aus Großbritannien? Also hier ich bin aus Großbritannien, also oh, traue für den den Tod. Der König in der so. Ich habe da nicht einfach geantwortet, oh ich bin für eine Brüsche Republik.
Und ich fand die Reaktion und auch in den deutschen Medien eigentlich ziemlich ungewöhnlich. Moment mal, also.
Hier sind so zwei so äh Länder ohne körperliche Familien und es gibt so ne.
Traurige Reaktionen, als ob dann
Das wäre etwas Gutes. Nie, das ist in sich selber nicht etwas Gutes. Und einfach so sehr schwierig ist für uns alle, auch für meine Eltern, ja also mein Vater ist in dem Jahr
zweiundfünfzig geboren, ja und die Königin,
begann dann an an der Drohne zu sein im Jahr zweiundfünfzig, in dem Jahr des Geburts von meinem Vater, ja? Also,
was die königliche Familie ist, ist für die Leute in Großbritannien und man kann es nie trennen von die.
Die Königin, die sind so eng verbunden. Wir wissen nicht, was ist eine moderne königliche Familie in Großbritannien, das wissen wir nicht.
Und ähm und es wird ja spannend zu sehen, wie die Situation jetzt sich entwickelt in den nächsten Jahren.
Kann sein, dass seine ernsthafte Debatte dann beginnt, was wäre dann die Rolle von einer, eine moderne königliche Familie, aber bisher
Hand diese Debatte nicht wirklich begonnen wegen die ständige die ständige andere politischen Krisen dann in den Wochen.
Ähm seit Anfang äh seit Ende, Ende September.
Was denkst du, was mit äh Charles jetzt zu erwarten ist? Er gilt ja eigentlich als eine sehr viel politische Person, du hast es ja schon erwähnt, ne. Er ist äh
gilt als jemand, der sich's schon immer sehr für das Klimathema eingesetzt hat, ich sage jetzt mal, er gilt. Ich weiß es nicht, wie viel da jetzt wirklich äh äh dran ist und er machte eigentlich immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck als würde er schon in gewisser Hinsicht einen anderen Stil
als seine äh Mutter. Wird der den jetzt aufgeben? Wird der den jetzt durchziehen? Denkst du, er wird mehr in eine politischere Rolle auch haben?
Wollen.
Das ist das ist ja schwierig. Natürlich.
Er hat bestimmt ordentliche Berater und diese Berater werden bestimmt sagen bitte.
Erstens so einfach möglichst dich so raushalten. Ähm.
Aber irgendwie wir haben schon dieses Beispiel mit einem Kopf 27 schon gehabt. Wir haben schon einen Film ähm äh kam auch raus aus der und sagte
oh you are again, oh dea ode hat er so gesagt, ja.
Das kam auch. Äh irgendwie aber sonst Art und Weise, ja, irgendwie nicht gemein gedacht, ja, aber irgendwie.
Bisschen blöd ähm.
Bisschen britisch, würde ich sagen. Also das.
Ja, nach dieser so Bomblinger Art und Weise irgendwie. Ähm es wird auf jeden Fall anders sein. Was wir.
Was man mit ihm sagen kann, ist, ganz ehrlich er ist nicht gemein. Er ist.
Irgendwie er will das Beste tun. Die Frage ist natürlich, für ihn ist was bedeutet das überhaupt heutzutage in die die die britische.
So in dem britischen politischen Zirkus. Ähm und das es könnte so eine Situation kommen, wo er wirklich so Entscheidungen.
Treffen muss in den nächsten Wochen oder Monaten, ja? Also.
Ja, also für mich ist es immer noch ein großes Fragezeichen. Ähm er hat bisher.
Keinen großen Fehler gemacht, ja? Äh aber es er ist nur im Amt seit sechs Wochen. Ähm es kann ja sein, dass es problematisch wird, ja. Ähm.
Ja, mehr kann ich zurzeit nicht sagen.
Gut, dann kommen wir doch mal wieder zurück auf die äh.
Und dann vor allem jetzt auf die letzten vier Wochen. Wir haben's ja schon erwähnt, List Russ äh musste sich dann erstmal medial etwas äh zurückhalten oder hätte auch gar keine andere Chance äh gab. Man könnte auch sagen, sie hatte zwei Wochen Vorsprung erstmal.
Ohne mediale Aufmerksamkeit ähm was vorzubereiten. Jetzt hat sie natürlich das Land zu einem Zeitpunkt übernommen, wo.
Die Probleme äh echt kulminierten. Also es gibt auf der einen Seite das auch von Boris Johnson.
Äh unterstützte und ich glaube auch unter Lyst Trust nicht wirklich in Frage stehende Engagement für die Ukraine.
Die damit verbundene Energie äh Situation, das haben wir auch alle schon erwähnt und natürlich dann äh die ganze Brexit Heritage plus eben der allgemeine Zustand der
ähm und natürlich ähm damit eben auch schon die angesprochene Schwäche, mit der sie ja jetzt hier eigentlich in die Rolle gegangen ist, weil sie eben diese Unterstützung der Partei so nicht hat. Jetzt hat sie ja erstmal einen
glaube ich, ganz bemerkenswertes Kabinett aufgestellt, was so,
die Diversität betrifft. Da hat sie wohl versucht einen Punkt zu machen, aber was sind denn da letzten Endes für Personen aufgerückt?
Ja also ganz grundsätzlich, also dieses Kabinett ist schon im Abend seit dem 6. September, aber auch dann wir haben erst nach der Beerdigung der Königin wirklich.
Gesehen, was tun die, ja? Tross hat so eine,
Ideologisch sehr schmal aufgesetztes Kabinett ähm äh ähm so zusammengestellt. Äh der.
Das schon raus, ja? Aber der der damalige ähm,
Finanzminister der ist eins von den engsten politischen Alliierten von Trus, also ist wirklich auf der rechten wirtschaftlichen Flügel äh der der Partei. Ähm,
Hat überhaupt nicht versucht, anderen Leute aus so anderen Flügeln der Partei irgendwie.
Wirklich reinzubringen. Also äh.
Also stellvertretender Premierministerin ist ähm sie ist ähm
auch eine langjährige Alliierte von von Trus und der Außenminister ähm
auch. Also sie haben versucht so eine Gruppe von so engsten Alliierten
um sich zu bilden. Leute reinzubringen wie wie könnte es ja so eine Rolle geben für ihn oder ähm
äh anderen Leute so aus der Ehe so pragmatischeren Seite der Partei. So im,
Das führte dann zu einer echt große Krise ähm am 32 September, sodann das ist,
sind nur vier Tage nach der Beerdigung,
der Königin. Also das ist eigentlich ausdünlich interessant. Also so ein normales Politik begann,
schon am 20. September wieder an. Ja, okay, Beerdigung ist vorbei, Politik beginnt wieder. Ja, also es das war ziemlich schnell und ziemlich beeindruckend. Also, der damalige Finanzminister
braucht das einen sogenannten 2022 raus. Das hieß.
Einen sogenannten mini Budget, so dem Minihaushalt. So das ist dann wichtig, weil in den britischen politischen Kultur muss ein Haushalt
durch den britischen
Unterhaus abgestimmt werden. Also es begann schonende Diskussion muss es ja eine Abstimmung geben über diese neue Finanzplan von quasi Quarten.
Und es begann sehr, sehr schnell wirklich schief zu laufen,
Die finanzielle Situation in Großbritannien war schon sehr problematisch, weil besonders wegen Energiepreisen die so rasant angestiegen sind
Mit den mit zwei Problemen im Hintergrund. Erstens, Großbritannien war Härte betroffen wegen der Coronakrise.
Als manche andere europäische Länder wirtschaftlich, meine ich und hatte schon größere Staatsschulden und wegen Brexit und wegen den sinkenden Wert
des Funkes und wegen Energieimporten äh Importen,
die dann in ähm äh gepreist sind. Waren dann diese Energiepreisproblemen, die dann dann schon sehr ernst waren von anderen europäischen Ländern, noch Ängste für Großbritannien erst dann für anderen.
Also was bedeutet das, den wirtschaftlichen Ausgangspunkt für Kurt Hang und Trass ähm Ende September war schon sehr ernst
Was haben die dann getan? In diese gab's keine,
unabhängige wirtschaftliche Prognose. Es gibt in Großbritannien ein Gremium, es heißt die Office,
Budget responsebility. So eine Büro für verantwortliche Finanzpolitik. Also da drin.
Sind es Beamte, aber die müssen oder haben immer die Finanzpläne der Regierung,
theoretisch unabhängig ausgewertet und gesagt, funktioniert das wirtschaftlich oder funktioniert das nicht? Also.
Quarternk hat so ein rausgebracht,
ohne diese unabhängige Analyse der Office und in dem Golfplan gab's eine Senkung der Einkommenssteuer für alle,
Eine große Senkung der Einkommenssteuer von 45 auf 40 Prozent. Für sehr reiche Leute, die über 150.000 Pfund im Jahr verdienen,
Es gab eine Reduzierung der Nation in, also das ist wie eine Art Einkommensteuer, was hauptsächlich den Britischen National Health Service finanziert. Also sehr große Steuersenkungen,
und mit dem Hintergrund, dass schon
Steuereinnahmen schon runtergegangen sind wegen den wirtschaftlichen Situationen
und Ausgaben schon erhört geworden sind wegen Subventionen für Staatsbürger,
oder normale Burger.
Wegen den erhörten Energiepreisen. Also das bedeutet Einnahmen waren schon runter, ja und die wirtschaftlichen Hintergrund war schon problematisch.
Also die Finanzmärkten haben so gesagt, he Moment mal, das geht einfach nicht. Wie kann man hoffen, dass mit.
Wenige Steuereinnahmen, ja, dass Wirtschaftswachstum kommt, also das war das Argument von von Corsy Cortain und das mit mir Wachstum,
das dann schließt den Kreis. Und den einzigen Option für mehr Wirtschaftswachstum wäre natürlich eine
wieder Eintritt in dem EU Binnenmarkt. Was die sehr euroskeptische und und und Liste natürlich als Option ausschließen.
Das führte dann zu kurzfristig dann zu einer Art ähm finanzielle Krise in Großbritannien.
Den Zentralbank, dann,
musste ähm Bonds ja also ähm Staatsschulden dann zurück kaufen,
Das führte dann zu historische äh Niedrigwerten der Fund gegenüber den Dollar. Also ähm er schärfte dann noch mehr,
die Krise und das führte dann inzwischen, dass obwohl Truss selber 100 Prozent Quad hängen unterstützt hatte,
Er war dann als Finanzminister dann schon am 14. Oktober gefeuert,
Er war dann den zwei kürzesten Finanzminister äh der der britische äh Geschichte.
Also das war dann eine kurze Zusammenfassung von nur die finanziellen Aspekten von den Mini-Budget, von von Quarten und von. Was haut an sie interessant ist, ist all das hat Tross während.
Der Partei Antenne Urwahl im Sommer schon gesagt.
Und niemandem hat das damals ernst genommen. Denn ich selber auch nicht, ja? Das kann sie nicht tun. Das wird natürlich nicht funktionieren.
Das wird so eine Krise führen.
Sie wird alles, was Sie dann die Parteimitglieder angeboten hat, einfach abgeben müssen. Also wir haben es einfach alle so selber so gesagt, so eingepreist. Ja,
sorry, das kann sie nicht tun. Wenn der Realität wirklich
kommt, wenn sie Premierminister ist, sie wird alles dann abgeben müssen. Jahrelang gesagt, ja ich will die ähm äh Steuerprozentsatz
äh aussenken können hat er nicht getan. Was schoss dann gemacht hat, war einfach mal
was hat sie getan? Und das führte dann Großbritannien in diese Parallele wirtschaftliche sowie auch politische Krise.
Also die Kritik an diesem.
Czess war ja auch nicht nur innerhalb von äh dann äh sofort da, sondern eben grade
einerseits natürlich durch die internationalen Märkte, Finanzmärkte et cetera, was du schon erwähnt hast, aber das ging ja bis zum.
Bis zu Joe Biden, der irgendwie äh öffentlich äh explizit diese Maßnahme,
hat und gesagt hat, das ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, weil seine Worte waren, aber äh nach dem Motto, das ist irgendwie nicht so eine gute Idee.
Das ja schon ziemlich bemerkenswert und äh ja da diese Reaktion hat auch damit zu tun, dass das Pfund ja auch immer noch Teil ähm der internationalen Währungs.
Sicherung ist. Also man kann sozusagen sich das gar nicht erlauben, dass dann eben das Pfund einfach mal so abfällt, weil es dann einfach Unsicherheit an den,
in jeder Beziehung ähm auslösen, alles sehr komplexe Zusammenhänge, verstehe ich auch nur so begrenzt, aber auf jeden Fall war die Aufregung dann doch sehr äh groß.
Ja.
Und und es führte ich versuche hier das auf Deutsch zu übersetzen. Er war fast die die.
Die finanziellen Journalisten benennen in ähm in Großbritannien zurzeit eine Idiot Wish Premien, so eine Art
Deppenzuschlag auf Deutsch. Wir haben versucht, das zu übersetzen. Das wenn man vertraut.
Politischer Entscheidungsträger nicht,
Das Herr ist herrsche da eine Unsicherheit in den Märkten und das erhört dann den Preisen,
um damit dann man will,
britischen Governments zum Beispiel zu kaufen. Es zu erhörte Zinsrahmen in Großbritannien
Und das war dann Einweggrund, warum dann, und das war dann den Beginn von den jetzigen politischen Problemen.
Für sie dann gefeuert hat, hat sie dann.
Jeremy Hunt zurückgebracht. Der war jahrelang.
Minister und ist auf der Sorte der pragmatischeren Flügel der Konservativen. Und der leitete
dann eine Art Kiewwende ein,
hey Moment mal, also diese Senkung der Steuersätze für für Reichen, Reduzierung der Einkommenssteuer und so weiter. Das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, also er hat alles den kompletten Plan von von und von einem Tag bis dem nächsten komplett gedreht.
Und einfach mal zu sagen, okay, wie Adolf Sebuck in Room, also das bedeutet dann, das herrschte dann hat dann geholfen, dann ein bisschen für ein bisschen mehr Ruhe in den Finanzmärkten hat das zu
begonnen, das dann reinzubringen. Das Problem da war dann.
Eine andere. Es hat die Finanzmärkten ein bisschen beruhigt, aber das hat die politische Situation für List Stross. Das hat das dann den kompletten,
Regierungsrichtung von,
komplett kaputt gemacht. Also sie hat dann gesagt, ja wir standen alle hinter dem kompletten Kabinett stand hinter diese Pläne von Tross und Quarten.
Und dann von einem Tag bis demnächst, also dem vierzehnten, 15. Oktober, haben die dann alles.
So geändert, alles so zurück zu den alten Johnson und und und Snack-Ära zurückgebracht
Aber dann wofür ist dann Truss? Wofür steht sie dann überhaupt,
Und das führte dann zu einer Art politische Krise bei TRAS. Also das bedeutet,
die Hardlines, die dann Truss unterstützt haben bei der Partei
interne Urwahl sagen. Hey Moment mal. Also wir wollten Steuersenkungen, jetzt kriegen wir genau das Gegenteil.
Was für eine Chance hat sie dann das überhaupt einzuleiten? Und das führte dann schon dann gestern zu,
Wir wissen nicht, ob es so wirklich eine Art Rücktritt oder ob sie gefeuert worden ist. Den Aus für den
Innenministerin, also die oh damalige Innenministerin Swellemann hat als Parteichefin,
gegen die anderen äh kandidiert. Aber wirklich von den noch weiteren rechten Flügel der Partei Astras und Snack und sie sagte, okay also
unter den jetzigen Umständen kann das einfach nicht weitergehen. Und alle denken dann, sie will sich dann positionieren für einen zukünftigen,
Entscheidung, wenn Trust dann als Parteichefin und Premier Mistance stürzt, das Spraywoman könnte dann äh dann kandidieren die Partei noch weiter nach rechts,
zu ziehen. Ähm also das ist grob den den jetzigen ähm äh Situation.
Die Partei zersplittert komplett aus so einem anderen Thema und das ist dann fucking. Also die Lösung vorgeschlagen von Trass.
Für eine Senkung der Energiepreisen.
Wäre dann Fracking für Gas ziemlich schnell wieder Einführung in Großbritannien. Gegen den Willen,
der der Britischen Bewölkungen, weil die wollen das nicht. Und auch 100Prozent gegen was die Konservativen
in den Parteiprogramm vorgeschlagen haben in zwanzig neunzehn, als Boris Johnson, das war Unterhauswahl
gewonnen hatte damals. Er hat damals einen kompletten fracking Verbot vorgeschlagen damals und jetzt will komplett
wieder einführen, also gegen den Willen der eigenen Partei
Und sie, das führte dann zu noch einer katastrophalen, parlamentarischen Situation gestern Abend in in ähm im Britischen Unterhaus. Als sie versucht hat
alle Parteiabgeordneten unter enorm viel Druck zu setzen, um fucking wieder einführen zu können. Also das führt dann.
Außerdem, wir wissen nicht genau, ob das zustande gekommen ist oder nicht. Zu der der der ähm.
Abgang von den Chief Web, also den ähm ähm Rücktritt der Chief Web äh Wendy Morden. Also was bedeutet, wir haben ja keine Ahnung.
Chief Fip darfst du gerne noch mal kurz erklären.
Also das ist die die ein Person, der für für für parteiinterne ähm äh Kohärenz der Fraktion, so eine Art äh der für der oder die Kohärenz der Fraktion zuständig ist.
Also äh förtlich übersetzt. Das ist also die Hauptpeitsche, ne, also.
Ja genau.
Person, die sozusagen hinter allen Abgeordneten steht und dafür sorgt, dass es eben ja ein einheitliches Auftreten äh gibt und es ist halt generell äh so ein bisschen so eine Hardliner Position auch immer im Kabinett, ne.
Also wir haben ja keine Ahnung, ob noch ist oder nicht oder sie ist im Amt, aber hat keine Verantwortung oder keine Macht mehr. Also.
Die Regierung,
von eine politische Krise bis die nächsten, ja ähm es es kann auch sein, dass Bravoman Worte zurücktreten nicht wegen den offiziellen Grund, was rauskam, sie hatte einen technischen
Sicherheitsfehler gemacht, ja ähm sie hatte.
Geheime Dokumente über den eigenen persönlichen E-Mail Konto verschickt,
Ja, das ist den offiziellen Grund. Aber in der Realität, wir wir haben gehört, dass sie wollte eine neue Regelung für Wiesen.
Füll.
In Großbritannien einführen, also viele internationalen Studenten, besonders auch China, Studierende in Großbritannien und die haben dann eine besondere Regelung.
Arbeitsvisum für die Zeit nach dem Studium zu kriegen. Und diese Regelung wollte Sweaterman als Innenministerin dann dann deutlich
Stränge machen schwieriger zu machen für für für Studenten, dann
nach dem Studium an Visum zu kriegen und direkt gegen den Willen von von Le's Charles. Also bedeutet, dass aus der gleichen Flügel der konservative Partei kommt wie Braveman, wollte
Bravoman, so eine Art Alleingang in Sachen der Visumpolitik der Regierung,
einfach selber einen Alleingang machen und dafür setzen Braverman unter Druck. Also es ist ja,
vollkommen schwierig.
Einfach diese komplette blöde Geschichte überhaupt zu folgen, weil man weiß ja nicht, wer tritt zunächst zurück
wer wird dann reingebracht als Nachfolger? Ist die Regierung überhaupt entscheidungsfähig? Also es ist.
Einfach katastrophal zur Zeit. Äh also ich habe selber in meine jetzt war 20 Jahren, die ich so sehe nah an British Politic,
gefolgt habe und auch wenn diese kompletten Krisen mit Brexit und und Theresa May und und wo im im britischen Unterhaus da gab's eine gewisse
wie wir Menschen sagen, also.
Dass alle, die in der Regierung sind, also in dem Regierungskabinett
haben eine gemeinsame Verantwortung gemeinsam die Regierungslinie zu vertreten. Und diese
Das funktioniert zur Zeit nicht. Ja, also,
selber keinen einheitlichen ordentlichen Team gebaut. Und es herrscht jetzt die Frage,
ist das überhaupt möglich, dass Trass das überhaupt in Griff kriegt oder kriegen könnte, ja, das wissen wir zur Zeit nicht. Also dann.
Was sind dann die Optionen? Also entweder Trus, regiert weiter,
aber come faktisch gar nichts tun, weil alles, was sie bisher getan hat
wird nicht die dem kompletten Mini-Bagget ist schon kaputt. Was kann die dann überhaupt tun? Also sie hat kein.
Agenda mehr, also sie kann nichts bemerken oder gar nichts tun und sie leitet jetzt einen Kabinett,
ohne so eine Art Gemeinschaftsidee oder Gemeinschaftside.
Oder die Alternative ist dann die konservativen ersetzen Listras.
Mit sonst jemanden. Aber wer könnte diese Rolle dann überhaupt übernehmen?
Weil was man nicht oder was die Abgeordneten nicht in diese,
riesen Seiten haben wollen, ist wieder eine parteiinterne Urwahl.
Weil man fürchte, dass wenn so was zustande komme.
Kriechmann, dann sogar Boris Johnson als Premierminister zurück und das ist ja kein Witz, obwohl es klingt so,
total blöd. Also dass die Abgeordneten sagen, hey, wir wollen keinen parteiinternen Urwahl, aber wenn die Partei,
armgeordnet sagen, hey Moment mal wir wollen die.
Mitglieder einfach nicht erneut fragen können, ja das führe dann zu einer.
Dort tiefere Spaltung zwischen die Abgeordneten und die Parteimitglieder. Das führe dann zu einer Art.
Partei, wo man das so parteiintern überhaupt nicht das ist nicht regierbar als Partei oder als Bewegung.
Die äh Einschätzung teilt ja auch die Bevölkerung derzeit offensichtlich, weil wenn man sich die aktuellen Umfragen schaut. Also es war ja immer so, dass Labour ja so ein bisschen aufgeholt hat, aber es gab nie wirklich eine nennenswerte,
Trend hin zu einer anderen Regierung,
glaube die aktuellen Umfragen sehen Labour irgendwie 30 Prozent Punkte vor äh den Torriss, die jetzt irgendwie bei 19 Prozent sind. Das ist ja das absolute Tief und das ist, glaube ich, das, was
die Torries immer am meisten hassen in irgendeiner Form nicht mehr an der Regierung zu sein.
Genau, also das sind die
besten Umfragewerten für Label seit Anfang der Neunziger, so heißt es vorher auch, eine parteiinterne Krise gab bei den Konservativen und äh äh John Major damals. Aber das,
ist auch ein Grund, warum Neuwahlen.
Zur Zeit eher unwahrscheinlich sind, weil alle konservative Abgeordneten denken, oh Moment mal, also wenn es jetzt.
Zu Neuwahlen käme, es ist ja unser eigene politische Zukunft ist.
Ist dann fraglich. Vielleicht, wenn wir als Partei mit sonst noch jemand dann ersetzen, der oder diese Person könnte die Situation dann irgendwie stabilisieren
Könnte das dann zu einer etwas bessere Situation dann führen. Ja und die haben ja vielleicht recht. Aber wäre das dann,
halbwegs demokratisch schon den dritten Premiere Minister seit den letzten.
Unterhauswahlen ja also es auch ja sehr fraglich.
Ja sagt man glaube ich, ne? Also sie können äh sozusagen nicht vor, nicht zurück und ähm ja Neuwahlen stehen erst 2024 glaube ich spätestens an, ne.
Alle spätestens Januar 20025 aber alle gehen davon aus, dass,
Es wäre normaleweise Herbst zwanzig vierundzwanzig, weil Großbritannien keine Tradition hat, vor allem in in den Wintermonaten zu machen. Das, was geschah in 2019 war so eine Art Ausnahme.
Tja ähm also es.
Wer könnte Nistrossel setzen und wie? Ja, das ist dann eine eine interessante Frage. Weil.
Wir haben in den letzten Podcast von den Parteiinternen Prozederen der Konservativen Gerede. Ganz grundsätzlich also wenn.
Wenn 15 Prozent der Abgeordneten,
der conservativen schreiben Briefe,
den sogenannten neuen das ist so eine Art
Ausschuss der Hinterbänkler der Conservativen. Beginne dann eine Misstrauensprozedere in der Parteichef der Conservativen. Also das,
haben die getan gegen Boris Johnson. Boris Johnson hat das am Ende überlebt, aber dann einen Monat danach musste er dann zurücktreten,
Das Problem ist in diese Regelungen gibt es dann eine eine Periode wo zwölf Monate lang es nicht mehr möglich ist diese Prozedere,
erneut zu verwenden, damit es dann dann eine gewisse Stabilität dann herrscht. Wir wissen schon, dass es ausreichend Abgeordneten gibt, die kein Vertrauen mehr haben in,
aber die Prozedere kann erst in einem Jahr beginnen.
Eine parteiinterne Misstrauensvotum in Lissras nach dem formellen Artenweise parteiintern zu beginnen.
Also das ist formell.
Ausgeschlossen. Es gibt die Diskussion, könnte man einfach dann diese Regelungen ändern, ja? Natürlich ist es auch nicht hervorragend als Lösung.
Zweite Option lies Trust tritt zurück. Also man sagt, hey Moment, lesen, so das geht nicht, bitte zurücktreten. Was wäre dann die Prozedere, Liz Trust Dan zu.
Zu ersetzen. Dann beginnen dann diese Prozedere das bei den Abgeordneten.
Man muss so eine Art von zwei dann etablieren. Aber faust dann zwei Leute dann in die letzte Runde dann kommen muss es dann zu den Parteimitglieder dann,
noch einmal dann gehen und es bestehe dass Gefahr, dass wenn diese beiden, die dann kandidieren, was die eigentlich dann wollen, ist so eine Art Situation, lass Theresa May,
in die letzte Runde kam gegen trat zurück
damit es dann keine parteiinterne Urwahl bei den Mitgliedergeber damals
Aber wenn zum Beispiel, es gäbe Swelle Braverman gegen Vishismark, muss es dann zu einer parteiinterne, uralte Mitglieder kommen und sowas braucht dann sechs sechs Wochen, so sorry so inisieren
Um mitten in eine politische und finanzielle Krise ist es dann möglich, dass Großbritannien politische Situation könnte dann einfach faktisch
sechs Wochen lang ohne klare politische Linie einfach da sowas zu überleben. Ja, das ist nicht klar.
Also ich meine eine klare politische Linie sehen wir ja eigentlich schon längere Zeit nicht mehr so richtig.
Genau oder es gibt auch Überlegungen, eine Art Olaf Scholz. Ja, das benennen die das nicht. Das.
Dass Trus Könte Parteichefin bleiben, aber die Abgeordneten wählen einen anderen Premierminister.
Gäb's eine Diskussion auch darüber, ja aber was der Situation ist, ist die parteiinterne ist, ist so tief problematisch, dass.
Leute hoffen, dass die Partei könnte sich also eine Art Notfalllösung auf eine Art.
Kompromisskandidat dann einigen.
Aber wer könnte so ein Kandidat dann sein, weil die Chassunterstütze, die hassen die komplette Prozedere, die sagen, das sei eine Art ähm äh,
Kuh ja gegen Truss, ja? Ähm also ich kann es überhaupt nicht sehen, dass die finden dann eine Art Einigung für.
Sonst noch jemanden. Ja, aber wir wissen, dass Trus.
Kann gar nichts jetzt machen, ja und.
Ist ja ich habe mich dann so sehr oft gefragt.
Wie könnte es zustande kommen, dass jemand, die so total unfähig ist wie Trus.
Wie könnte so jemand überhaupt Premierministerin werden?
Und die Wurzeln sind so sehr tief in die,
sage ich die moderne britische politische Kultur. Und diese politische Kultur Brexit führte zu diese moderne politische Kultur.
Fähig zu sein irgendeine Ahnung von was wirtschaftlich eine gute Idee wäre,
war nicht in vogue, also diese we don't need experts any more Linie von Michael Google während der der Brexit-Referendumskampagne. Das.
Seit 2016 ist die ganze britische, politische Kultur.
So komplett realitätsfern geworden.
Wenn man versucht hatte jemand wie Trus unter Druck zu setzen, sagen hier Moment mal, sowas funktioniert nicht.
Vordersamtwort, ja, wir müssen einfach ein bisschen mehr in das Land glauben oder an Brexit glauben oder die.
Die Möglichkeit des Brexits einfach mal Härte durchsetzen können,
Das waren eine Reihe von sehr unseriöse Menschen, Leute, die unter sage ich normalen, politischen Umständen.
Nie unter Druck wären, ja.
Jahrelang war Lea beliebt unter konservativer,
Mitglieder, besonders in den Jahren zwanzig neunzehn und 20 20.
Sie war damals ähm Trade, also Handelsministerin.
Und sie hat einfach diese Handelsverträge mit anderen Ländern der Welt
unterschrieben. Wir wir haben eine eine Handelsvertrag mit Neuzählern, die unterschrieben, ja, im Wert von 0,01 Prozent der Bruttoinlandsprodukt. Es setzt nicht, was groß
mit der EU hatte. Aber enorm viel Applaus. Der Applaus der der konservativen Parteimitglieder. Also.
War fast zehn Jahre lang ein Minister in Großbritannien seit 2tausendzwölf.
Und wir haben nie irgend Sie waren nie unter Druck. Wir hatten nie den einen irgendeine stabile Meinung von was will sie tun?
Das ist eine so ein komplettes Versagen der der komplette öffentliche politische Diskussion. Es ist alles so, überflächlich, ja.
Und in den Worten von den Hinterbänkler ist es es lohnt sich das das anzuschauen. Dahinter Pankle Charles Walker ein Konservativer.
Er hat äh sich zu den Thema gemeldet gestern. Er hat gesagt, wir haben einfach jahrelang.
Unfähige und unseriöse Menschen den höchsten Emden gegeben, einfach weil die.
Die richtige politische Linie unterstützt haben jahrelang und.
Und was dann ist den Weg zurück? Hört Großbritannien jetzt den tiefsten Punkt.
Jetzt erreicht.
Das das Hand zurückgekommen ist als Finanzminister. War das dann den tiefsten Punkt? Man kann sagen Hand ist Hand immer noch ideologisch ziemlich weit nach rechts.
Aber es ist weniger Realitätsfern als Truss oder Kraten oder Wismark äh oder Braverman. Ja?
Elsorück ist das eine,
Wände. Vielleicht.
Aber die politische Karriere von Truss ist auf jeden Fall tot. Es gibt kein Weg zurück für Trus.
Keinerlei. Die Frage ist nur, wie lange kann sie im Amt bleiben und wer könnte dann schon.
Überhaupt ersetzen. Die sind dann die großen politischen Fragen.
Jeremy mir Hunt selber da ein Kandidat?
Gute Frage vielleicht aber er war.
Am 20. Juli so unbeliebt ja, dass er hat es überhaupt nicht geschafft, in den letzten sechs kandidieren zu schaffen.
Um Parteichef zu werden.
Also äh bei den Oval unter den Abgeordneten zählten er nicht zu den sechs populärsten damals, ja, in Ende Juli.
Was natürlich auch daran liegt, dass dass das gesamte äh die ganze Fraktion äh der Torries natürlich alle mehr oder weniger solche äh Borussia Johnson Jubel Perser äh sind oder zumindest zum großen Teil.
Ja und auch halbwegs feigen haben so gedacht okay wir müssen irgendwie unterstützen also und,
wenn man hört, was Leute sagen überhand
Ja, dass er sei macht nur, was die Finanzmärkten wollen, von ihm wollen, dass er korrupt sei keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich stimmt, ja, aber,
das kommt aus den eigenen Rängen der konservativen ja also.
Man hat den Eindruck, dass diese Partei überhaupt nicht mehr zu verreinigen,
ist. Das Einzige, was gegen Neuwahlen spricht, ist die haben alle Angst vor Neuwahlen.
Also.
Werden wir jetzt sehen, wie sich das äh entwickelt. Ich frage mich jetzt, kann das dann auch.
Im Prinzip auch das Ende oder zumindest der Anfang vom Ende sein, dieser
Ideologie, die sich so mit dem Brexit Referendum 2016 jetzt im Verlauf der letzten,
schon sechs Jahre Bahn gebrochen hat. Also kann das einfach sein, dass auch das Ganze Brexit-Denksystem damit langsam zum Einsturz
kommt. Hältst du das für möglich.
Es ist möglich aber es wird lange dauern bis wir den Punkt wirklich erreichen.
Deswegen sagte ich ja auch, es ist vielleicht der Anfang vom Ende.
Es ist Anfang jetzt stürzt, das ist einen wichtigen,
Startpunkt. Den einen noch wichtigeren Punkt.
Ist dann bei den nächsten und Hauswahl, weil dann hoffentlich verlieren dann die Konservativen. Und den dritten wichtigen Punkt ist, wann beginnt bei Labour eine Art Überlegungsprozedere.
Wie sähe dann einen besseren Verhältnis zwischen Großbritannien und die EU aus?
Weil's zur Zeit Laibern besonders die finanzpolitische Sprecherin der Label Partei sie sagen,
Wir sehen oder wir wir werden aus Labour Partei die,
des Brexits besser ausnutzen können, aus die Konservativen.
Ich sage, es gibt ja keinen Vorteilen des Brexits. Ja und das hat Labour bisher nicht erkannt. Also das wäre dann den die dritte Etappe, das Labour erkenne dann
Okay, wir müssen auch einen nicht erneute EU beitreten, sondern.
Etwas bessere Verhältnis besonders wirtschaftlich mit der EU wäre dann,
Also was wäre die dritte Etappe? Also tschüss raus,
Etappe eins Just Etappe zwei verlieren eine Unterauswahl, eine Etappe drei Labour Förder, dann eine ordentlichere Beziehung mit der EU. Ja also die sind die, die möglichen Nächsten Etappen.
Also wirtschaftlich, denke ich mal, gibt's ja eigentlich nur den Weg, einzusehen, dass man eben in dieser total isolierten Stellung keine Chance hat, weil meine.
Zahlen sind ja relativ klar, ähm alle G7 Staaten haben äh sich sozusagen nach der Corona-Delle wieder gefangen
und äh mit der Ausnahme eben von UK, die halt so auf so einem niedrigen Plateau verweilen und halt.
Tendenziell auch noch weiter einbüßen können. Es ist ja auch überhaupt nicht absehbar, wie eigentlich Großbritannien da raus will oder kann
gibt da einfach keinen keinen wirtschaftlichen Weg. Das heißt, die einzige Option
die sicherlich manche auch schon realisieren, aber die einfach im politischen Klima des Landes nach wie vor schwierig zu vermitteln sind, ist zu sagen, wir müssen mindestens irgendwie der Customs Union
beitreten, so würde ich das mal sehen, womit sich ja auch das Nordirland-Problem äh schon mal reduzieren
würde. Äh der nächste Schritt wäre natürlich zu sagen, wir müssen auch Teil des Single Markets in äh werden in irgendeiner Form, so ne, also so eine Assoziation, so ähnlich wie Norwegen, äh das hat warte mal, Norwegen ist oh Gott.
Ähm und äh ja,
womit man natürlich dann wiederum in so einer anderen Dilemma äh Situation wäre, dass man ja quasi vollständig den Regeln der EU ausgeliefert ist.
Aber eben überhaupt gar kein Mitspracherecht mehr hat. So und das ist ja schon mal so läuft ja schon mal so komplett dieser Brexit Ideologie entgegen.
Aber irgendwie ganz grundsätzlich irgendwie das Großbritannien hat alleine.
Diese für sich alleine diese Krise ausgedacht irgendwie, ja. Dass die EU sei nicht schuld, dass ich schon ein wichtiges Kenntnis für die britische öffentliche politische Debatte.
Und du meinst, die kommt oder die ist schon da.
Die ist schon da. Äh das das Brexit.
Ein Grund dafür sei ist vielleicht nicht komplett bekannt.
Aber das niemandem wirklich Schuld ist für die jetzige Situation außer die Briten selber ja das ist schon bekannt, kriege ich den Eindruck aus den aus den letzten paar Tagen.
Ne, das ist ja schon mal ein äh.
Das schon war's, ja.
Das könnte wirklich der Anfang äh vom Ende sein in gewisser Hinsicht, ne? Ja vielleicht sollte man ja auch nochmal ganz
kurzen Blick noch mal auf die Sezessions äh Bestrebungen, die es ja auch immer unterschwellig äh gibt
werfen, also nach wie vor steht ja die Ankündigung von Niklas Dörging, der Premierministerin in Schottland aus, dass sie äh ja eigentlich in diesem Jahr äh das Referendum ähm ab
halten wollte über eine weitere Unabhängigkeit von Schottland. Auf der einen Seite auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja in Nordirland, die im Übrigen
das ja auch in Bezug auf Brexit auch noch mal so eine interessante Wahrheit. Der einzige Teil des Landes sind, die überhaupt
keine nennenswerten wirtschaftlichen Probleme haben oder zumindest eine eine stabile äh äh Situation haben, weil sie eben noch über Irland und damit eben mit der ganzen EU ähm Handel treiben können.
Trotzdem gab's dort jüngst auch das erste Mal glaube ich eine Umfrage, die jetzt eine klare
oder zumindest überhaupt erstmal eine Mehrheit, vielleicht noch keine klare Mehrheit, aber zumindest eine Mehrheit für eine äh Regionification mit äh Irland.
Also wie läuft's in an der Front? Das ist natürlich derzeit kein primäres Thema, weil,
so wie anderes das überlagert, aber das das ist ja irgendwie unterschwellig auch immer noch da und da bilden sich ja auch weiterhin Meinungen.
Also.
Da gab's Gerüchte aus Brüssel. Also ist das Verhandlungen da, um faktischen Lösungen für die Probleme an an der Grenze nach Nordirland.
Die Verhandlungen liefen weiter in Brüssel in den letzten paar Wochen ja und führte zu einer etwas.
Bessere Atmosphäre, dass man könnte kurzfristig Lösungen
für diese Problemen, besonders die Kontrollen auf den Fähren zwischen dem Rest von Großbritannien und und und Nordirland. Also da war die Stimmung ein bisschen besser. Die Stimmung in Schottland war,
ziemlich negativ, also Nicola Störgin sagte auch vollkommen zurecht, hey Moment mal so.
Wir so ein Steuerpolitik wollen wir in Schottland nicht und im die einzige Lösung wäre da nun Unabhängigkeit. Aber keine Ahnung also ob wie das dann weitergeht, was.
London ist überhaupt zurzeit überhaupt nicht in der Lage, Entscheidungen zu treffen. So, was Schottland die irgendwie braucht, ist.
Irgendeinen stabilen Ansprechspartner in London, was man bisher nicht hat. Und es kam.
Letzte Woche vielleicht heraus, dass es gar bisher auch kein Telefonat zwischen zwischen äh und Nicholas Sterging. Also hat auch den Eindruck gegeben, dass die,
sie will auch Brücken nach Schottland überhaupt nicht bauen. Ähm also ganz grundsätzlich die Situation in Richtung Nordirland sieht kurzfristig einen pragmatisch.
Kleines bisschen besser aus, aber mittelfristig bleiben ganz, ganz viele Fragen offen und in Richtung Schottland
keine Ahnung. Man man braucht eine gewisse Stabilität in in London, was grad nicht herrscht. Also mehr zu dem Thema.
Können. Ich denke, können wir zur Zeit nicht sagen.
Aber ist denn das Problem, was du angesprochen hast mit den Fähren und den Kontrollen wirklich auch ein Problem für Nordirland oder ist es eigentlich eher nur ein Problem für Großbritannien?
Es ist ein Problem für.
Es ist ein politisches Problem für die Not irischen Juniisten. Die sagen, diese Kontrollen sind so eine Art Trennung, das Trenne Großbritannien von Nordirland.
Ähm und das ist das ist mir so ein politisches Problem als ein.
Problem ja natürlich ist es schwierig, weil alles kontrolliert werden muss. Ja, aber es ist mehr ein politisches Problem als ein faktisches Problem, aber das,
Das betrifft auch Nordirland. Es ist nicht nur in Westminster.
Tja also wir stellen fest äh es ist immer noch alles ganz schön durcheinander und äh das Durcheinander nimmt tendenziell eher noch weiter zu.
Ich ähm ich meine so aus einer deutschen Perspektive heraus.
Ich denke, da hat sich dann auch in Deutschland, glaube ich, in den letzten Jahren relativ wenig verändert. Das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch so wahrnehmen. Hier sitzt man dann doch eher noch immer so ein bisschen mit der
Tüte äh und schaut sich das Geschehen so von außen an, ne? Das ist so, man hat da so sein.
Und man denkt sich halt die ganze Zeit die spinnen die Briten was ja wahrscheinlich auch tun und ähm.
Was allerdings mir dabei
und das begleitet auch unsere ganze Serie eigentlich von Anfang an immer noch so ein bisschen, was mir da so ein bisschen zu kurz kommt ist halt das Problem
dass es eben in keinerlei Interesse von Deutschland und Europa an sich sein kann dass diese ganzen
Auflösungserscheinungen, die das Land zeigt, sich äh weiter fortsetzen. Weil man weiß ja auch, solche politischen Instabilität
wenn die sich noch weiter verfestigen, äh können dann auch jederzeit immer mal wieder zu neuen Radikalisierungs ähm Bewegungen führen. Gut, die hatten wir jetzt im Prinzip mit dem Brexit bereits
oder eben auch einfach die wirtschaftliche Schwäche, die sich letzten Endes daraus ergibt, ist ja auch nicht gut. Ich meine äh man verliert ja auch äh
die also die ganze wissenschaftliche Kooperation, dadurch dass halt äh nicht mehr in dem Horizont-Programm teilnimmt äh also da da sterben ja auch Verbindungen, die ja für
alle gegenseitig von Vorteil waren, ne? Es ist ja äh es war zwar immer so ein bisschen schwierig mit diesem auf der Insel und man dachte sich halt schon immer so, meine Güte, könnt ihr mal irgendwie
wie? Kommt doch mal klar. Ja, aber äh immerhin, es gab diese äh politische Integration
so schwierig sie auch war, aber sie war halt.
Da und am Ende ähm hat ja äh das Land auch davon profitiert, auch wenn sie das halt dann sich das selber eingeredet haben, dass es nicht so ist. Ne, also aber das diese Erkenntnis könnte ja auch mal wieder
zurückkommen und grade jetzt in der äh Situation mit dem Krieg sieht man ja auch wieder, wie wichtig,
ist halt äh eine europäische Gesamtlinie zu finden und und wie schwierig das auch äh nach wie vor und immer noch ist das zu finden und gerade wenn man sich die Auseinandersetzung anschaut äh mit.
Ungarn jetzt im Besonderen mit ihrer starken Antihaltung ja ähm Polen natürlich äh auch noch, auch wenn sich das
auch wenn das grade so ein bisschen zurücktritt unter die äh Eindrücke des Krieges ähm wäre es ja schon,
hilfreich, wenn eben ein weiterer Powerplayer wieder zurück in die EU kommen würde und dann ist halt auch die Frage, kann ja Deutschland kann, also was kann die EU,
tun? Um
diesem Drama dort in irgendeiner Form wieder einen Weg aufzuzeigen. So also,
kann es ein Angebot geben.
Ja aber ganz ganz grundsätzlich auf die britische Seite ist es,
weit zu früh über einen erneuten EU-Beitritt Großbritannien zu reden. Man weiß ja nicht, auch kurzfristig, wie wie sieht alles politisch aus in Großbritannien.
Mhm. Ja, das ist.
Außenpolitik ist die britische Unterstützung für die für so für die Ukraine dann genauso stark wie sie vor. Also da da muss man keine Feuchtung haben. Und eins von den einzigen hardwegsfähigen
ähm Politiker, die noch in dem Kabinett von ähm ähm dem noch in dem Kabinett von von Truss ist, ist Walles, der der der Verteidigungsminister. Also
da muss man nicht so viel Angst haben.
Was wir auch gesehen haben, ist die EU hat etwas auf diese diese Situation so gelernt, also wir wollen nicht, was gerade auf der Insel so passiert. Also das ist etwas auch ziemlich Wichtiges. Also,
meine Hoffnung wäre es, dass die EU sagt, okay, wir wir sind offen für Vorschläge aus Großbritannien.
Aber nicht so schnell, alles ganz ruhig, alles braucht jetzt ein bisschen Zeit. Großbritannien muss noch,
ganz grundsätzlich äh über seine eigene politische Zukunft zu Tiefe denken.
Dann ist dann ein zu den wieder Beitrittstür dann vielleicht wieder offen.
Es ist nie schwierig für deutsche Politiker oder französische Politiker zu sagen, hey Moment mal also wir haben gezeigt, dass die EU wirkt.
Ja? Dieses Argument ist für Scholz oder Macron ist einfacher heutzutage zu machen als als vielleicht vor dem vor dem Ausdeberin.
Ja
Was denkst du, was steht uns als nächstes bevor in diesem in diesem Spiel haben wir uns ja eigentlich auch schon zu geäußert, ne?
Die Frage ist natürlich kurzfristig ist.
Jetzige Krise überhaupt überleben, ja, auch sogar heute überleben. Die Chancen sind.
Ehe dagegen. Ich denke, dass die Chancen, dass in den nächsten paar Wochen die Konservativen Finn eine Art.
Ersatzpremierminister irgendeine Art Interim Premierminister.
Sind höher als die Situation, als Lysters dann da bleibt. Und so jemanden könnte so eine Art Kabinett.
Mit Leute aus allen Flügeln der Partei dann irgendwie aufbauen.
Ich denke, dass sowas von Hand oder oder oder Synak geleitet wird, ist vielleicht eher unwahrscheinlich, weil die vielleicht kommt irgendjemand zurück, ja aufs alten Zeiten, ja wie Michael Google vielleicht?
So ein bisschen mache mir ja so Angst, dass goog äh jemand für die Realität wäre, aber gut ähm.
Und dann die Regierung könnte die Situation halbwegs stabilisieren für die nächsten paar Monaten.
Ja bis irgendeiner andere Krise in den nächsten Monaten. Also das ist das wäre meine Vermutung.
Ja das und er keine Neuwahlen, dass man hat gesehen, dass.
Das ganze britische politische System ist auch nicht so wirklich demokratisch,
Ja, also man hat schon einen Premierminister ersetzt mitten in diese Wahlperiode. Man macht das einfach noch einmal. Okay.
Weil was den wichtigsten Punkt ist für die konservativen ist die die haben ja Angst vor Neuwahlen. Also die werden alles tun um Neuwahlen zu vermeiden ist meine zurzeit meine Vermutung,
Ich sehe nicht, dass es ausreichend konservative Abgeordnete gibt, die wirklichen,
wirklich einen Demokraten sind und sagen hier, Moment mal, so kann es nicht weitergehen, so für das das Gute des Landes wäre es besser, ein,
ein Unterhauswahl zu machen und den die jetzige Regierung mit Labour irgendwie so ersetzen. Das ist grob meine Vermutung, ja dass,
Keine Neuwahlen, so eine Art Ersatz vom von Lis Trash. Das ist die wahrscheinlichste und diese,
schlechten Varianten.
Nun gut.
Schauen wir mal, was äh passiert und wie schnell uns die äh Ereignisse wieder zusammenführen.
Woche.
Ja. Na ja, ich denke, es war äh und ist auch nach wie vor hilfreich, hier auch immer in so gewissen
äh zurückzublicken, ne und äh
die Dinge da nicht so im im Tagesverlauf oder auch Wochenverlauf zu bewerten, weil es geht einfach äh so wild hin und her und es ist äh ein Schauspiel, was
Ganz unterhaltsam war auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich könnte jetzt auch mal wieder auf ein anderes Thema langsam. Also das wäre schon ganz gut, aber ich glaube äh
als Ideologie ist etwas, was ja.
So langsam aus den Köpfen weicht, so schnell es da reingeraten ist. Gut, das hatte natürlich seinen Vorlauf in gewisser Hinsicht. Das haben wir ja auch äh ganz zu Anfang auch schon besprochen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Ideologie, die jetzt einfach keinen Saft mehr hat, aus dem sich so recht keiner äh ernährt und jetzt ist es glaube ich eher so eine Frage.
Wer traut sich äh zuerst aus der Deckung einfach mal zu sagen, dass der Kaiser äh keine Kleider hat, ne? Also es ist äh ich habe auch so bei Labour immer so das Gefühl,
Ich meine, du hast vorhin gesagt, Leber hat noch nicht verstanden, dass Brexit keine Vorteile bietet. Da habe ich dann doch so ein bisschen gezuckt und dachte mir so
bitte also.
Das müssten die doch eigentlich auch sehen und ihre Zurückhaltung ist eher eine politische Zurückhaltung, weil sie meinen, mit so einer Position.
Bevölkerung nicht anzukommen.
Ja. Ja, aber.
Da glaubt doch keiner jetzt wirklich da dran, ich meine das ist doch einfach alles viel zu offensichtlich. Ich meine es ist ja alles was,
in Anführungsstrichen Projekt vier so vor, du hast ja da auch diesen Artikel zitiert, ne, Projekt vier was right vom Telegraph, der nun nicht unbedingt gerade für das Verbreiten dieser Position bekannt ist.
Dieses dieses Angst ja hat immer noch. Leben traut sich immer noch nicht die wahre Realität.
Zu präsentieren. Wenn Großbritannien ein Weg zurückhaben will, wirtschaftlich so wie politisch das führt so eine.
Tiefgehende Überlegung, wie sehen die Verbindungen mit der EU politisch so wie wirtschaftlich aus?
Es gibt kein Weg das zu vermeiden aber den politischen, kurzfristigen Kalkül von Labour ist nein wir reden nicht darüber, Punkt.
Das muss als Meinung dringend geändert werden. Die Frage ist, was kommen wir zuerst? Eine Unterauswahl oder diese tiefgehende Überlegung der Labo Partei?
Ja aber es hat volle Angst. Ja, wenn wir darüber reden, ja, wenn wir in den Meinungsumfragen sogar Prozentpunkte verlieren.
Das haben die immer noch, auch heute noch.
Ciao. Gut, wollen wir an der Stelle einen Punkt machen? Ich denke, es ist alles äh gesagt, also sage ich äh nochmal vielen Dank für deine Ausführung, Ton.
Alles klar, herzlichen Dank ebenfalls und ähm ja, bis die die nächste britische politische Krise.
Genau, die ist sicherlich nicht äh nicht weit entfernt. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei UKW äh irgendwann machen wir mit diesem Thema äh wieder weiter Ukraine wird natürlich auch fortgesetzt und so weiter, ja bis dahin äh.
Euch noch einen unterhaltsames äh Politgeschehen. Ich sage tschüss und.